[Musique]
et
non
au président kita france emmanuel macron
et on complète et aussi
[Musique]
la possible sur les terrains annexes
et
c'est pas le brésil qui a commencé je
suis dans cette situation-là sapeurs
pompiers on est là pour ça les
politiques brésiliens mettre de l'huile
sur le feu les politiques brésiliens les
politiques italiens les politiques
français tous les politiques vivent de
st on le sait on le sait
[Musique]
c'est triste mais c'est triste d'abord
pour lui et pour les brésiliens
moi je pense que les femmes brésiliennes
ont sans doute honte de dire ça de leur
président et comme j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié de respect pour le peuple
brésilien
j'espère très rapidement qu'ils auront
un président qui se comporte à la
hauteur
le